SIERRA: Thoughts about Africa can fall into
cliches. There’s the romanticized image of endless
natural beauty - waterfalls, rainforests, golden
savannahs dotted by elephants and lions. And then
there’s this idea of Africa as a perpetual
humanitarian tragedy - famine, epidemics,
violent coups and bitter tribal conflicts. Yes,
Africa has all of these. But the problem with
cliches is that they often make you miss the real
story. And the real story is that the world itself
is becoming more African. Fast. Projections show
that by 2050, Africa’s current population of 1.4
billion will double. That means that one out
of every four people on Earth might be African
just thirty years from now. Throughout this vast
continent, country after country is undergoing
an enormous youth bulge. In several, more than
half the population would not be old enough to
buy alcohol in the United States. In Uganda the
median age is 15. Some see a future in which this
massive, youthful population propels African
nations onto the global stage in a way that
could mirror the rise of China. But other experts
say that without massive new job opportunities,
this rapid growth is a recipe for poverty,
radicalization, and violent conflict.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It
Matters. Today, the world’s African future.
DW AFRICA:
Africa’s population is growing fast.
CNBC INTERNATIONAL: This population boom
will be dominated by one continent, Africa.
BBC WORLD NEWS: While the boom
in numbers brings opportunities,
there are also many challenges like
all those extra mouths to feed.
TED: Have to unleash the genius
of our young people. Get out of
their way. Support them to create
and innovate, and lead the way.
GITHONGO: I always tell people, the trains run on
time in Switzerland, but I've not heard of notable
thriller writers from Switzerland. The thrillers
are coming out of places that are developing,
where everything is changing, it's funky, it's
difficult. And I think that really Africa's future
is in its youth. My name is John Githongo,
I am CEO of Inuka Kenya and publisher of The
Elephant. I've been involved in anti-corruption
work and media for 33 years, around the world.
SIERRA: John is an activist and a journalist who
fled Kenya after exposing government corruption,
and returned in 2008. He spoke with
us over zoom from his home in Nairobi.
SIERRA: So, is that your kids
we hear in the background?
GITHONGO: Well, you know, I live
in an apartment block. And with
the COVID pandemic, the poor guys.
You know, they're out there all day
and sometimes late into the night.
They play out in the front here, so.
SIERRA: Wow, that's lovely.
GITHONGO: Yes, absolutely. One of the sad things
that has happened in Africa is because Africa is
so rich in terms of natural resources and remains
the world's richest continent in terms of,
you know, looking for gold, or the the
minerals used to make mobile phones,
solar panels, they they come out of Africa, this
has been a curse for us. Our primary resource is
our people. Africa is the world's youngest
continent, most rapidly growing population,
as a net contributor to the world's population
as the other continents sort of are slowing down
or shrinking in terms of population. We had
1.2 billion people on this continent in 2016,
and will be, you know, 2.5 billion by 2050. And
that trajectory is going to continue like that,
I think. And so yes, people call it you
know, it's a youth bulge. So this new young
generation of Africans are very worldly,
very precocious, and much better informed,
the best informed generation we’ve
ever had. Citizens of the world.
SIERRA: It’s important to note that in this
episode we’re going to be talking about
Sub-Saharan Africa. Forty-six of Africa’s
fifty-four nations lie entirely or at least
partially below the Sahara desert. The world
of international relations tends to think of
these forty-six nations as a group, whereas the
six nations of North Africa, all members of the
League of Arab States, are usually thought of as
being part of the Arab world. There are problems
with this model, but it is widely used.
GAVIN: In most African countries,
70% or more of the population is under the age
of 30. So there the whole demographic
profile looks really, really different.
Hi, I'm Michelle Gavin. I'm a senior fellow for
Africa, at the Council on Foreign Relations.
SIERRA: From 2011 to 2014, Michelle was
the United States ambassador to Botswana
and served as the United States representative
to the Southern African Development Community.
GAVIN: These are youth dominated societies
and that has all kinds of really interesting
implications for politics and economics. We live
in an interdependent world and Africa is going to
be able to sort of assert itself on a global stage
and the concerns of those young Africans whose
numbers are vast, whose backgrounds are incredibly
varied, whose circumstances are incredibly varied,
but their concerns are going to find expression in
African foreign policy and in African engagements
at international institutions. And both
with these demographic numbers where so
much of the world is going to be African, and
the fact that it is 54 countries, which means
a lot of votes in international forae. Things
aren't going to get done without African help
and important US priorities aren't going to be
addressed if there's massive African resistance.
SIERRA: Okay a whole lot to unpack there!
But maybe a good way is to start local.
What does it even look like to walk around
in a place where just everyone is so young?
GAVIN: Yeah, I think, sometimes at least, there's
a certain kind of reporting from the continent
that unfortunately, always seems to start off
with, you know, as I stared out the window of my
taxi, I noticed groups of young men, you know, on
the street corner. I felt a sense of unease. And
it's problematic in lots of ways. Right? But, I
think it springs from just people being unfamiliar
with societies that look so incredibly young.
There's no time you're going to be walking out on
the street when you don't notice a lot of groups
of young people, because people are very young.
SIERRA: The median age in India is around 27. In
the United States it’s closer to 38. In Canada
it’s around 40. And in Japan it’s closer to
50. Compare that to the median age in Nigeria,
Africa’s most populous nation, which is 18. Every
country has its own demographic concerns. Japan is
facing a dwindling population that could endanger
its status as one of the world’s most powerful
economies. Africa’s outlook is the opposite,
and the scale of the trend is off the charts.
So why did this boom happen? Is there
a reason that this is happening now?
GAVIN: Well, so, most of the world has gone
through sort of a demographic transition,
but there are sort of generalizations one can
make where societies tend to have higher birth
rates at a certain era and usually at the same
time, there's also very high mortality rates. So
basically, families have lots of children, and
many, many families lose children as well. And
then over time, and there's lots of factors that
contribute to this, women's education being a
huge one, access to family planning. Over time,
people tend to choose smaller families and sort
of the population pyramid, if you can picture
it, with kind of children at the bottom and
your most elderly members of society at a point
at the top. Over time that pyramid starts to,
instead of being really wide at the base,
you know, sort of get taller and pointier.
And Africa is sort of at a stage where there’s
still pretty high birth rates, large families,
but there have been huge advances in health, and
people are living longer, children are surviving.
SIERRA: According to the World Bank, in
2018 Sub-Saharan Africa had an average
fertility rate of 4.6 births per woman.
This has gone down significantly since
the middle of the 20th century, but remains
far higher than in many other parts of the
world. At the same time infant mortality
has plummeted and life expectancy has
shot up. To put it simply, far more
Africans are being born than dying.
GAVIN: This is something that happened in
East Asia right back at the time of their
massive economic expansion, and it was something
called the demographic dividend. The idea being,
suddenly these societies had a huge number of
working age in their prime people. And were able
to kind of harness that amazing potential to make
these huge economic development gains. There's
innovation all over the continent. And this is one
of the things that doesn't get enough attention,
right? You know, just like any other part of the
world, there's good news and bad, but there are,
you know, amazing tech entrepreneurs in Nigeria,
in Kenya, there's incredible scientific research
that gets done in Dakar in Senegal. There's
a lot. But is there any place that's got
a, you know, clear roadmap for how to generate the
jobs of the future, that is definitively going to
be successful? No, because, you know, there's a
host of unknowns. You know, most African societies
do deal with pretty high rates of unemployment
that, that's a little misleading, in that the
informal sector is incredibly robust in a lot
of African countries. And sometimes, what looks
like a bunch of society being unemployed just
means that employment’s happening in an informal
sector. But there too when you think about the
kind of infrastructure and educational needs for
these vast growing societies, eventually, you're
going to have to formalize that sector if you're
going to do the sort of revenue generation
that's required. So there's a lot there. But,
you know, different societies, again, of
course, look different, right? Nigeria,
with its incredibly large population, or
Ethiopia, with its huge population look very
different than a Botswana with, you know, about
2 million people in a country the size of France.
SIERRA: There are a range of projections for
where Africa’s population boom is headed,
and the most common ones tend to be pretty grim.
Financial Times: The population of
Africa is set to almost double by 2050,
raising fears that progress in fighting
poverty and disease will be reversed.
CNBC International: According to recent
research, between 18 and 20 million jobs
will need to be created across the continent over
the next 25 years. And if that doesn’t happen,
millions of unemployed young people will become a
perfect recruiting environment for both militant
Islamist group, Boko Haram, and human traffickers
selling dreams of a better life in Europe.
CGTN Africa: In 2011, Kenya had a population
of about 40 million. 68 percent of that figure
were between the ages of 15 and 35 years. 70
percent of these youth are currently unemployed.
SIERRA: Are there jobs for all these young people?
I mean, competition must be off the charts.
GITHONGO: No, economies haven't been
able to create the jobs. But we also
recognize that the traditional economy
is dead anyway. That the economy that
you train to become an accountant and get
hired into a firm and you’re apprenticed,
and then, you know, develop etc. and
stay in that profession–that the very
nature of work is changing. And so the
most adaptable and creative young people
are or are doing that are very much on top of
global trends. And therefore, there are many
who are struggling but there are also many who
are who are thriving in this very fluid context.
SIERRA: The traditional career models that many
Africans expected to pursue as they grew up are
out of reach. It’s a problem that’s probably
familiar to many American young people as well.
The difference is that in Africa these young
people make up a far larger percentage of the
population. Given this difference in scale, many
experts are reluctant to share John’s optimism.
Some think that even with innovation, the
rate of population growth will inevitably
outpace job creation, and that part of
the solution has to be to curb population,
perhaps through initiatives that fund women’s
education and access to birth control. The Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation is one of the
most prominent proponents of this strategy.
Bill Gates: They’re faced with an almost
impossible problem. Northern Nigeria,
Yemen, Chad. And so, what we need to
do is take this a-generosity and this
innovation and go into those places. Offer
the women better tools where they want to,
space birthing, or -or have a smaller family
size, and improve health. Because it’s,
amazingly as children survive, parents feel
like they’ll have enough kids to support them
in their old age, and so they choose to have
less children. https://youtu.be/ozlbeXrb_5A?t=57
GITHONGO: You know, Bill Gates
talks about it a lot and all that,
that really irritates Africans. I mean,
okay, very clever guy, very good hearted guy,
he wants to do the right thing. But this
is really none of his business about the
population. We have, we have enough space.
Our problem is not population in Africa,
it's governance. It's the fact that we
have corrupt leadership, and poor systems.
GAVIN: When I think about all the challenges kind
of inherent in the demographics of the continent,
I don't think that bringing birth rates down
is at the top of the list. Right? I don't
necessarily see the situation, and again, it's
different in each place. It’s not that, “oh,
my goodness, there's a problem to be solved here
and it's high birth rates.” Right? It's much more,
you know, how does a society move forward in a
way that's sustainable given you know, that there
are enough resources for all and where people
can have opportunity. I think there's no way to
sort of get through that without increasing
access to education for women and girls,
then birth rates end up falling out at the size of
a family, you know, adult women choose to have. So
I don't think one needs to kind of have an idea
in mind of where they'd like to see fertility
rates plateau out to. Women sort that out all
by themselves when they have some choices.
SIERRA: We’re going to take a quick break,
but when we get back, is Africa’s population
boom a blessing or a curse? And how
are other countries responding to it?
SIERRA: When I was doing research for this
episode, it seemed like a lot of pieces,
were examining this youth population boom,
and breaking it into two buckets, either,
an opportunity, or they called it
a ticking time bomb. So it felt
like they were very much putting it
into these very specific categories,
a blessing or a curse. Do you think you
could sort of break that down for me?
GAVIN: It does tend to be this really binary
read on this. So there's a school of thought
that suggests that, all these young people
without a clear path of economic opportunity,
right, are ripe for radicalization,
that there's likely to be violence.
And, is that one possible scenario? Well,
sure, absolutely it is. I don't think that
necessarily happens organically, right?
But if there are actors out there trying to
radicalize or trying to mobilize southerners
against northerners, or what have you,
it does create maybe fertile ground for that kind
of destabilizing sort of societal mobilization.
Then there's the, look at this incredible
potential, look at this vast amount of human
capital, right? All this kind of latent potential
that just needs to be sort of harnessed to a set
of economic projects and goals and, and then you
have the incredible, you know, manpower of Africa,
finding expression in economic development
and growth. And all of it’s true, right? At
the same time. You have all of it, it just really
depends on what specifically one is talking about.
GITHONGO: You know, life is complicated.
That's the nature of life, and it's full of
contradictions. So, it’s a bit of both. In
countries where the the governance systems
and the leadership is weak, or corrupt, or
incompetent, then it becomes a curse because
you're unable to provide for, you know, for
this younger generation that that want jobs,
that want an income, that want health, that
want education, and that frustration boils
over and causes instability. But
I'd like to think it's a blessing,
because with youth comes energy, comes
idealism and that's what a society needs to
develop. And the pace of development is quite
unprecedented across the continent. I mean,
I visit a country and then go there five years
later, and just the level of development in
terms of infrastructure, and just what young
people are doing and how they're doing it.
GAVIN: So in addition to being the youngest
part of the world, Africa is also the most
rapidly urbanizing part of the world. And that,
you know, again, a host of things flow from that,
some exciting, some really challenging. So
there's lots of issues around affordable housing,
urban infrastructure, water, transportation,
etc. It also has really interesting political
implications because it is easier for young
people, particularly young adults to organize
in an urban environment, it's easier to share
information, it's easier to engage in the kind
of activism that tends to demand a response from
authorities. And so we have seen a huge uptick in
demonstrations, in peaceful demonstrations
in a host of different African societies.
GITHONGO: And in the next 20 or so years,
some of the world's largest cities will be
in Africa. Lagos, Dar es Salaam, etc, will
be giant mega cities with 10s of millions of
people living in them. But across the rest of
the country, we have gigantic cities that are
growing very quickly, organically, and a lot
of the trade is increasingly within Africa.
SIERRA: And as Africa continues to urbanize,
goods and services are not the
only thing flowing across borders.
Truly the one thing that jumped in my mind first,
when I heard just about a continent full of very
young people is that the art, the music, the
literature, the culture, it must be so incredible.
GAVIN: There's so much going on. Absolutely.
The filmmaking, the literature. Yeah,
there's a lot coming from Africa that
I feel like we're starting to get more
of a taste of in our own kind of cultural
diet. But there's a lot we're missing, too.
GITHONGO: And for this young generation of
Africans keep in mind, they are borderless.
This young generation is very connected to the
African American community to the afro-Brazilian
community. Combine the fact that, you know,
especially in the arts and culture and language,
this is one community, and increasingly think
like that. And so there's a new sort of,
African sensibility and sense of Africanness.
And they're able to connect into global movements
and zeitgeists with great ease and quite
seamlessly than the previous generations.
SIERRA: And of course, shifting cultural views is
just one part of what these
new generations care about.
SIERRA: I mean, do you foresee
big political shifts? As you know,
these young people demand more say?
GAVIN: Absolutely. I think, as young, particularly
urban Africans, demand more from their government.
So more accountability, more service delivery,
and more of a sense of voice and agency in where
their government’s going. I think it changes the
nature of politics in a really interesting way.
And I think that it comes, you know, at a time
where, in part because of its demographic might,
we're seeing African countries be more assertive
on the world stage anyway. So I think this
sort of idea of African agency, both at the
domestic level in Africa's many democracies,
and at an international level in terms of African
engagement with international institutions, I
think this is kind of the big trend that's coming,
that everybody's going to have to reckon with.
SIERRA: And what we’re seeing in this
borderless interconnected world of arts,
culture, and politics, is that some
countries are rushing in to invest.
Of these outside investors, the largest is China.
GAVIN: You know, if you fly into an African
airport, the chances are pretty good that it
was built by the Chinese, that the road you're
driving on was built by the Chinese, that the
port you pass is built by the Chinese. There's
been tremendous investments in infrastructure,
and particularly very kind of tangible
and visible infrastructure and, you know,
parliamentary buildings, the things that everyone
can see. So the Chinese have been engaged
throughout the continent for a very, very long
time, they're the most important trading partner
to the African continent. They provide financing
for a lot of these big projects. They used to
provide a lot of the labor, that is less true as
there's been pushback from African societies. And
the Chinese are tremendously engaged in seeking
political influence on the continent and present
themselves very specifically as a contrast to
Western partners. There's a big emphasis still,
on non-interference in, in others
political affairs, and they point to
their own, you know, dramatic economic growth,
and their impressive development story as sort
of one to be emulated. And, you know, it comes
with this other package of political values.
GITHONGO: China commercially, is now Africa's
most significant partner. And that has grown
exponentially of course, they want the raw
materials, but they also need a market for what
they’re producing. As, you know, the markets in
the West become more and more difficult. I mean,
there’s trade trade challenges with the US, for
example. So there's a lot more anxiety about
China in the West, than there is in Africa.
There are problems, people like me who are
involved in anti corruption work are very
critical of the fact that yes, they enter
into very significant public works contracts. So
we've seen a lot of a lot of building of roads,
stadiums, schools, has improved infrastructure
tremendously. There's been a lot of corruption
accompanying it, partly because the contracts
are very opaque, and their system doesn't
allow any interrogation of how these contracts
entered into, of kickbacks with pay, it's very,
very difficult to establish. We've acquired
a huge amount of commercial debt from China,
which is causing us tremendous problems in
a number of countries and that that day of
reckoning is coming. But I don't think it's
a relationship that is going to slow down. We
see same thing with India, Turkey, Iran. All
of a sudden they're very present in Africa.
SIERRA: You know, I was listening to the
countries you were listing there: India,
Turkey, Iran, but I did not hear you say the U.S.
GITHONGO: You know, it is- the US is, at
once, hugely inspiring. Tremendous soft power,
people want to be like the US. Many of
the constitutions that have been written
in Africa since the 1990s after the fall of the
Berlin Wall, resemble the U the US Constitution.
The US’ own political system, which seems
to be based on a gridlock kind of approach
to politics. So you have multiple
checks and balances, which is good,
but it means that very often, you know, at the
last minute, the government has no funding for
the government and the congressmen and
senators have to sit down and agree,
it seems to have been designed by the founding
fathers deliberately to force people to to to sit
together and agree and we're seeing that system
fraying. Particularly over the last few years,
with President Trump being in office and what has
happened to the Republican Party and social media,
which has shown very startling the treatment
of people of color. That has caused a change
in consciousness about the US. So for the first
time, you know, you have, you know, the dream of
every parent is to get your child was to get the
child educated in American Ivy League University,
not so much anymore. We have a lot more students
going off to India, to China, even now to Turkey.
So US is still a hugely important partner to
Africa, not so much commercially. The commercial
relationship between Africa and the US is minor
compared to the relationship with India or China.
SIERRA: And how young Africans see the
U.S. is important, because they are the
ones who are going to make choices about the
relationships their countries make with the
rest of the world. Whether they will want
to reforge a bond with the United States,
or continue to embrace the ready
investments of China and other countries.
Do you think that the US is doing a good
job of forging partnerships in Africa?
GAVIN: So I think that there are many very
capable public servants and private citizens
doing good work, but no. I think I think that
the Trump administration has been kind of
disastrous for the US image in Africa. The set
of unforced errors, kind of insulting language,
dismissive diplomatic approaches. I don't think
that the US private sector still is as engaged
as makes sense in trying to seize African
opportunities. So when I was in government,
often hear lots of complaints about,
you know, the Chinese are eating our
lunch. But sometimes when there were
major tenders, major opportunities,
you wouldn't even have any American firms bidding.
So I don't know how you can complain about the
Chinese or pretend that this is all because of
corruption, when no one even was in the mix. So
there is a tremendous amount of work to be done.
And I do think it starts with exactly what this
whole conversation’s been about. It starts with
Americans getting more aware, more educated.
SIERRA: Because it does seem like this,
with this much at play, there are so many
strategic and economic opportunities to
be a constructive part of Africa's boom.
GAVIN: Absolutely, but it requires,
you know, acknowledging kind of what
African interests are and looking for
that overlap in the Venn diagram with
our interests. As opposed to imagining
this vast continent as some kind of,
you know, gameboard for your geopolitical
competition with some other major power,
or thinking of Africa as some kind of extra
credit altruistic exercise, which is absurd,
right, and leads to, you know, some very poorly
thought out types of engagements and initiatives.
SIERRA: So do you think that African
nations need help from the outside
to handle this well? And if so, what
type of help? What's the right help?
GAVIN: I think that, yes, in the sense that
there are big challenges that no one country
can possibly address alone. What I don't
think is that what's required is, you know,
a bunch of consultants sort of parachuting
in to design jobs programs, or, you know,
I love entrepreneurs too, and Africa is full of
exciting entrepreneurial stories. But if you look
at the sheer numbers of what we're talking about,
right, you're not going to entrepreneur your way
out of this problem of how to create these jobs,
right? Everybody isn’t going to start their own
business. That's insane. That's not the kind
of numbers we're talking about in terms of the
number of people who need work, work that is going
to provide enough for them to have a dignified
life and provide for their families and afford
that. So I think there's a global conversation
that people have been having about the future
of work that very strangely, rarely seems to
include Africa. It's nuts to me that people sit
down in Davos to talk about the future of work
and nobody's speaking from the point of view of
the, the part of the world that's going to have
the largest labor force. You know, when there
are these pat answers around entrepreneurship,
around leapfrogging technologies. Some things
can't be lept over, right, like roads, and
ports, and sort of the infrastructure that China
tends to fund. That is, you know, it's just an
essential part of what's going to have to happen.
So, you know, that kind of financing that China
provides that the rest of the world by and large,
does not, is going to continue to be needed.
GITHONGO: The most profound reality facing
Africa is demographic. That's why I was keen
to participate in this conversation with you,
because I think the issue that you've chosen is
the defining issue for Africa. Is, what do, you
know, is how, what happens to this generation
that is so young, and is growing so fast, is
going to determine the future of Africa. And
it will be determined by what Africans decide they
want for themselves, plus, the relationships that
are now the old relationships that
are being rekindled with the East,
etc. and ties with the West that are now sort of
just basically, it's not that they're being cut,
but it’s simply that other nations are
rising. And as the world changes, how
we're able to take advantage of that for our own
political, economic, and social benefit is key.
SIERRA: Whether this youthful energy is
harnessed for innovation and economic progress,
or whether it spirals into unrest, poverty
and radicalization, remains to be seen. But
it’s sheer size will inevitably impact all of
us. Some nations have long since realized this,
and are moving quickly to invest in Africa and
influence its course. Others, like our own,
are moving slowly, and as a result may lose out
on forming a fresh bond with a population that
could one day make up one third of humanity.
Africa’s power will exert itself economically,
it will exert itself with its mass of votes in
international bodies like the UN, it will be an
essential ally in combating global challenges
like epidemics and Climate Change.Africa’s
boom is inevitable. It is already happening.
The question is this: will we be part of it?
For resources used in this
episode and more information,
visit CFR.org/Whyitmatters and
take a look at the show notes.
Have a question or some feedback? Feel like saying
hey? Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio. AND,
please please, if you are a fan of the show,
show some love! Give us five stars and leave
a review on Apple podcasts. It means so
much to us and it helps us get noticed.
Why It Matters is a production of
the Council on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by
Jeremy Sherlick, Asher Ross, and me,
Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer is
Markus Zakaria and our intern is Senniah
Mason. Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor,
and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Original music is composed by Ceiri
Torjussen. This episode also featured
music by DJ Maphorisa, DJ Raybel. Extra
help was provided by Claire Felter and
Elena Tchainikova. Special thanks go
to Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke. For
Why It Matters this is Gabrielle
Sierra signing off. See you soon!